our old friend steve sibelius uh is
joining us from the las vegas review
journal uh
good to see you again steve long time no
chat
thanks for having me it's you know it's
it's only been a moment
since the 2020 general election um but
there's already some jockeying for
position going on right now
in nevada for some high-profile races
down the line
let's talk about a couple of key ones
and just kind of get a flavor of what's
happening on the political
ground first of all with governor
what is what is the moving and shaking
going on particularly on the republican
side of who might run against governor
sicily
yeah you're absolutely right john i mean
each year earlier and earlier the cycle
starts
sooner you know normally we wouldn't see
any kind of
talk about the governor's race the 2022
races until after the legislature is
over now we're doing it
during the legislature i think
eventually we're going to get to the
point
where it's going to start happening
immediately after the previous election
or maybe
even before so uh you asked about
governor
uh on the democratic side uh obviously
steve sislak
is the incumbent and uh he is uh
planning to run for reelection or at
least all indications are at this point
that he's going to
plan to run for re-election uh there
have been some whispers that he's
he's not going to do it uh but i happen
to think that if that was the case he
probably would have
said so maybe if shortly after the
legislative session concludes he'll say
so
if he's not planning to do it but right
now all indications are
that he is going to run so there you
have the the democratic side now on the
republican side
uh there's some there's something
interesting going on that you don't
always see you have a trio of candidates
that really bubble to the surface
and then those candidates are
representative mark amade of the second
district
lives up in reno the
the former lieutenant governor mark
hutchison
who is also a former state senator and
clark county sheriff joe lombardo
they both live down here in southern
nevada um
and what's what's interesting and and
somewhat unprecedented is that those
three are
talking they're having conversations
behind the scenes
with each other basically on the premise
of look a
a republican primary where we all run
against each other
spend all the money and come out wounded
and poor
is not in the best interest of the party
so we need to agree
amongst ourselves who is the best
candidate and then that person
will run without having to deal with a
republican primary with high
name contenders there's going to be
probably some people who get in
who you've never heard of but just the
top people and so
those three are the names we hear most
often
but it would also seem there are some
other names that are out there on the
republican side former senator
dean heller might want to run for
something again
there is uh adam laxalt still uh looking
for pace possibly running for
office one more time are those are there
some other names besides those three
that you're hearing
might jump in i understand that it's
still a long way away
it is still a long way away and uh there
are some other names interestingly
enough
uh dean heller has been mentioned he
wanted to run for governor before but he
deferred to adam laxalt
i think he may regret that decision now
given that laxalt uh performed so poorly
in the general
uh but we still assume regardless of
that performance that adam laxalt will
perform well in a republican primary
so he is going to be a formidable
candidate regardless of which race he
chooses right now
looks like he's going to run for senate
if he wants to do that
but we've also heard names of folks such
as
state senator ben kikefer of reno heidi
gansert
also of reno and also a state senator uh
potential candidates
uh to get into that race as well they
have some disadvantages their name
recognition is not very high in southern
nevada which is obviously where most the
voters live
and they're both moderates and that
brings up a really good point john and
that is this
can a moderate republican someone such
as a
mark hutcheson or or a ben kikefer
win a republican primary what does the
trump base
do in adam laxalt's case we know what
they'll do they'll turn out and vote for
laxalt no question
but a moderate is that person going to
get support
in a republican primary that's an open
question and that could really affect
some of
the candidates here and i would imagine
also aside from
you know where that uh former president
trump base would go
there's also there's the pure issue of
money where is the money in the nevada
republican party
of where would the supporters go would
it go towards a more moderate
angle as you were talking about those
three sort of names being whispered the
most right now
or more towards say adam laxon's
that and and that really comes down to
to the pragmatism of politics if you are
giving money
and uh and promoting a candidate based
on your heart
you may prefer a more conservative
candidate but if you're a pragmatist
you look at steve sisilak who despite
all the criticism
against him as a very moderate uh to
conservative democrat you look at him
and you say
in order to defeat him we have to have a
moderate
to conservative uh uh republican so we
need somebody in that
range and that person who is going to be
a great general election candidate may
not be a great
primary candidate so you have to
convince the base
during that primary that look the best
chance that we have
of winning this seat having a republican
governor again
and defeating steve sislek is to have a
moderate republican
but i don't know that that logic is
going to uh be accepted by
a lot of the base i think the base wants
someone who is perceived as a fighter
like
donald trump somebody who's not afraid
to mix it up to to dish out insults on
twitter and on the campaign trail
and and uh that's not mark hutchinson he
is he is not that guy
so uh while uh it's the oldest dilemma
you know while he would be a
a great general election candidate is he
going to be a good primary candidate and
that
factor really is probably part of the
discussions that's going on
right now amongst the three top
candidates before we move on from the
the governor's race
on the democratic side obviously as you
mentioned there's steve sisolak he's the
incumbent he is a democrat
you mentioned he's in all likelihood
good or run again but is it possible
given the recent
changes with the nevada democratic party
that he could be primaried
it is possible i have heard more than
once from
more than one person the name marilyn
kirkpatrick
as a potential candidate uh for uh for
governor she's done
a really good job as chairwoman of the
clark county commission
and uh and i think she might have
aspirations
uh to do that um i think that
might be less likely um uh you you
mentioned the democratic party and
whether or not
a progressive uh candidate a more
liberal candidate in the mold of bernie
sanders
uh would would challenge uh steve cyslek
for for governor
i i tend to think that that is probably
not likely
and the reason i say that is that the
the people who took over the
the state party while they are
definitely progressive and more liberal
than steve siselek there's no question
about that
i think they realize that they have
stewardship of this party now
and if they were to go and primary an
incumbent governor the first
democratic governor to to reign in
nevada in 20 years
i think they would lose credibility lose
the ability to raise money
and and run into other problems down the
road so i think it's less likely you'd
have a progressive challenger to steve
syslect and you'd have
maybe somebody like a marilyn
kirkpatrick who is more in the mode of
the incumbent
but just has a different style and of
course has her own history in carson
city
as well from from her past and the
legislative
uh let's look ahead to another big race
on the horizon for 2022
uh senator catherine cortez masto's seat
i guess it's kind of the same discussion
what names mainly of republicans
are lining up to try and raise money and
maybe
take her on is it a lot of the same uh
roster of fault you were just talking
about for governor
yeah the roster's a lot shorter than the
senate race because right now
it's a repeat of 2018 in the governor's
race and that is adam laxalt is said to
be interested
in challenging catherine cortes master
for senate
and as a result of that a lot of other
republicans are sort of shying away from
that race
now i would think based on the general
election performance that adam laxalt
had in
in 20 uh i'm sorry in 2018
that uh these other republicans wouldn't
be scared
uh to to take him on to basically say
look uh he ran a statewide race
uh against uh steve sislock he lost he's
not the guy
to represent us against catherine cortez
masto who's probably the most formidable
democratic candidate going through um
and
uh but that's not the case adam laxalt
if he gets into a primary will likely
win
a primary and so republicans are kind of
uh taking a step back and saying well
we're going to wait to see what he
decides
before we decide to do it now if he
doesn't do it you know the floodgates
will open and you'll have
the ben key covers the heidi ganzarts
maybe somebody who elected not to run
for governor decides to run for state
senate instead but really
everyone's waiting on laxalt to make the
call at this point
and obviously because of the way the u.s
senate is right now and how divided it
is
not just senator cortez masters
obviously all of the seats
could conceivably sway which way the
senate goes but
is she a vulnerable senator right now
would you say at this point in her in
her
term in the senate is she someone
politically
weak enough in terms of popular opinion
that she could be beaten
uh could she be it's always
theoretically possible that she could be
beaten but i think it's going to be
tough
and it's going to be tough for a couple
of reasons one she is now in leadership
she took on a very uh unenviable task
and headed up the democrats uh
campaign committee last time and against
all odds
barely by the hair of her chinny chin
chin got
the the senate to be evenly divided 50
50 and now with vice president harris
uh a a a slight advantage for the
democrats
uh and so that was something that people
didn't expect was going to happen
and she presided over that she has a
leadership post now
which means the democrats are going to
defend her and they're going to defend
her seat with whatever resources she's
going to need to keep that seat
and so i think you're going to see a
huge amount of money no matter who runs
there's going to be a huge amount of
money spent in this race
uh on both sides and so i would say
of the two if i was running i would
rather be cortez masto than sisilak i
think syslag is probably more vulnerable
because of the
criticism that's been heaped upon him by
uh
the uh his handling of the of the
coronavirus although a poll that the
review journal conducted not too long
ago
found his favorability above is
unfavorable
so it may not be as bad as we see on
social media probably nothing really as
bad as we see on social media
but i think she's going to be very tough
to beat because she's an extremely
disciplined candidate she does not make
mistakes she doesn't blurt out things
before she thinks about them and she's
got a good record to go on i mean
passing
of the coronavirus relief several
different iterations of that
if this infrastructure bill passes uh
the benefits to nevada from that
a lot of things that she can she can
tout as reasons to return her to office
one other major story of the week uh is
the
change from uh john lee north las vegas
mayor uh
a lifelong democrat now goes on fox news
and says he is a republican
what is your reading of the motivation
we spoke with him as i'm sure you have
as well
what is your reading of the motivation
and what are we not hearing about what
the long-term uh impact of that decision
is for
his future and just kind of what's next
yeah i i think um i i i think this
is probably less surprising than
the attention has been given to it uh
and we have all given
attention to it because he's a
high-profile person he's the mayor of
the third largest city in nevada
um but in in another sense john lee has
never really been comfortable
as a democrat he has been courted to
change parties since his time in the
legislature
he was served in the assembly and the
senate and he was approached numerous
times to change parties
because he was such a conservative
democrat
i take him at his word that he thought
that the recent changeover in the nevada
state democratic party
uh where people who are affiliated with
the democratic socialists of america
took over he thought that was he said
that was too much for him his values
didn't align with that and so he was
going to switch
uh to the republican party um but
uh i think really what's going on the
heart of your question is you know
the the why why now after all this time
uh would he do it and uh obviously the
answer for that
is the answer to some of these other
questions which is a possible run for
governor
um he uh steadfastly refused when i
talked to him
to talk about that he said he's happy to
be mayor i just want to focus on being
mayor
but he did say something interesting and
that is he affirmed what he said in 2017
when he got elected to his second term
that he was not going to run for a third
term
so that means he's open and available
and has time on his hands in 2022
uh when the next governor's race is open
so
i think he is looking at that as a
potential race going forward
and so i think that's really the
motivation at this point
um he he is a conservative democrat he
knows that running as a democrat against
steve syslak in a primary was probably
not uh the way to go
uh but in on the in the republican side
you know a guy who is formerly a
democrat
businessman helped turn north las vegas
around that's a good story to sell
on the republican side as well so uh so
i would suspect that we may see that
happen in 2022 it just that he's not
willing to talk about it
right at this point he wants to talk
about the apex water line a little bit
more
yes yes well it's got a good story to
tell an apex that's uh that could be the
uh
that could he called it the bread basket
of southern nevada and and
i don't disagree with that i think that
has a lot of potential it's a big
project to be sure
steve always good to see you sir and
look forward to reading you in the rj
sounds great thanks for having